موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اهلا بكم
اصدرت المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه قرارا
يقضي بمنعي زعيم حركه درعي من تولي اي
حقيبه وزاريه في الحكومه والتي يشغل فيها
حاليا حقيبه الداخليه والصحه انتقدت حركته
القراره ووصفته بالسياسي غير المعقول
بينما استبعد زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه وامريكيه بان وفدا من
الكونغرس الامريكي يزور اسرائيل
مشاركين في حكومه
الوسائل بان رئيسه الوفد طلبه اشتراك
ممثلين عن حزب العظمه اليهوديه وحزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه اللذين يتراسهما كل من
الاجتماعات
زمن ذلك مع زياره مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكيه جاكسون لاسرائيل وقال البيت
الابيض بين سلفا سيؤكد خلال زياره اهل
اسرائيل دعم الولايات المتحده لحل
الدولتين نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قوله ان الهدف من زياره سيرفا
لاسرائيل هو توضيح ما تتوقعه واشنطن من
نتنياهو والحكومه الجديده بشكل لا لا [__]
فقالت وكاله بلومبرج عن مصادر ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي
وضعها مركبات سترايكر المدرعه في قائمه
المساعدات العسكريه القادمه لاوكرانيا
جديده كجزء من مساعدته من الحلفاء
الغربيين لي اوكرانيا خلال اجتماع وزراء
الدفاع في المانيا يوم غدا الجمعه
هذا ولد الرئيس الاوكراني بلودي
ميرازيلينسكي لا تسريع خطوات تزويد بلاده
بالاسلحه الثقيله قبل حصول اي هجوم روسي
جديده وبينما اكد حرف الناتو ان الحرب
تتطلب توفير مزيد من الدبابات
روسيا الحلف بشني حرب ضدها انطلاقا من
اوكانيا
18 شخص بينهم وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
ونائبه في حادث تحطم مروحيه بالقرب من
روضه اطفال في ضواحي العاصمه
وقع الحادث في ضاحيه روفاري شرقي العاصمه
اثناء الثورها الى احد خطوط الجبهه في
خارج كيف وقد ما تعيينه قائد الشرطه قائما
باعمال وزير الداخليه
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يعطوني
بلينكن اهميه التعاون بين بلاده وتركيا
كحليفيين رغم وجود بعض الاختلافات على حد
تعبيره وعقبه محادثات بين ابلنكن ونظيره
التركي في واشنطن قال بيان المشترك ان
الوزيرين ناقشه تعزيز الشراكه الدفاعيه
بين واشنطن وانقره بما في ذلك تحديث اسطول
طائرات اف 16 التركي وشهود مكافحه
الارهابه
والسويد وتركيا للمضي قدما في طلب
الانضمام